[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Mike Mike goolock here
Mike Senior he was there he was working
for Westwood one and uh he joins us on
behalf of
DraftKings uh what kind of fine would
you give momes what would you give Andy
Reid for being critical the officials my
God Todd 75 in a when he said 75 thought
7500 yeah I did too 75,000
15 gotta send a message gotta send a
message I'm not gonna have this oh my
God you how quickly that would be
appealed Dan I'm more around you about
15 20 each I think that that would be it
and I'm sitting there trying to figure
what they're complaining about it's one
thing if if it's a subjective call like
with Valdez scantling against Green Bay
that's subjective that was interference
they just didn't call it where this he
lined up off sides and and God I love
Andy and I have known Andy for years but
was he just waiting for a warning on
that I mean it I was talking to Richard
Sherman about this this morning and he
was like it's amazing they don't give
defensive players any kind of warning
he's like I line up off Sid you're off
Sid and I said the same thing I line up
off sides I'm not getting a freaking
warning and even in my game last night
with the Cowboys and the Eagles when the
Eagles got into one of their brotherly
shove formations their left guard Landon
Dickerson lined up in the neutral zone
his hand was in the neutral zone he
didn't get a warning all of a sudden
they want a warning you you know what
look over the ref and ask because I
asked Richard Sherman if you look over
to the ref and ask will they answer you
he said yes they'll give you a thumbs up
or you know if you're good or tell you
to back up so man you can't just expect
a warning there it was egregious how
offside he was and he wasn't even truly
out like a wide receiver he was
basically a little bit past where the
tight end is he's right there
and look in I mean I I I don't know what
they have to complain about this wasn't
a subjective call at all yeah I don't
know why cadarius Tony is trying to
cheat a little bit because it it's
really not the play is not based off him
getting down to the end zone he's only
10 yards off the line of scrimmage your
point on that is a th% correct we would
try as a d lineman try and crowd the
line to get an advantage to kind of get
a quick jump off and be right into the
old lineman so sometimes we I've lined
up in the neutral zone and I'm right
over the ball it's inexcusable but I've
done it because you're trying to get all
the space you can to gain a quicker try
to gain a quicker Advantage he's gaining
no Advantage At All by by being that
close so I'm with you I don't understand
it at all all right um is it more about
the Cowboys and how they looked or the
Eagles suddenly look a whole lot more
vulnerable than they did maybe a few
weeks ago go you know like anything else
Dan it's probably a little of both the
Cowboys look great right now and one of
the keys as we talk about Dak having an
MVP year CD lamb you know he was the
only receiver going into this game over
500 yards in the slot and as a receiver
he's been incredible Jake Ferguson in
the middle of the field but their old
line which has two Hall of Famers on it
and Tyron Smith the left tackle and Zack
Martin at Right Guard who have been
nicked up the last couple years they're
healthy Tyron Smith has the best
blocking pass blocking pressure
percentage the lowest of any left Hackle
in the league Tyler Smith the guard is
number two and the Right Guard Zack
Martin is number three they're healthy
that's been a big part of them being so
good their defense has been good from
the beginning this year and for
Philadelphia they've had injuries in the
secondaries one one of the reasons they
went got got bued from Tennessee they
got sha Leonard from the Colt after they
cut him because they've had some
injuries at the linebacker position the
only real stable position there is the
defensive line line where they have good
depth they're giving up way too much in
the middle of the field on passes and
I'm telling you Dan watching Jaylen last
night it looks like his knee is bugging
him and and he's been wearing that that
like sleeve or brace and let me just say
when you play week to week you know
what's not happening you're not healing
all right you're just staying status quo
and trying to keep your head above water
it looks like he's affecting him and it
looked like in some of the passes as
there was beginning to be some pressure
that he was bailing on some of his
throws when you're throwing Crossing
routes that's got to be the ball's got
to be zipped so you can hit your
receiver in stride so they get yards
after the catch his receivers a couple
of times on those routes had to kind of
slow up and when they caught the ball
the defender would be right there to
make a tackle and what is Dak doing
differently let's say in the last or I
don't know if it's just Dak but it feels
like the offense changed from what Mike
McCarthy wanted was a running attack
back at the beginning of the year I I I
think Dak is reading coverages better I
think that's where I think Jaylen last
year took a step in that direction I
think Dak has as well because to me
always for a quarterback the most
important column for me is the
interception column and you see he had
15 last year and six this year he's not
turning the ball over where Jaylen had
coming into the game 10 interceptions
and lost four fumbles and lost one again
last night so I think Dak is reading
better the pass protection is good again
because of the healthy old line which is
giving him a little more time and and
and protection in the pocket and and
like I said I think he's just reading
and throwing the ball better than he did
last year where last year he's trying to
fit it in and there were Tight Windows
last night by the Because by the way his
completion percentage wasn't great last
night compared to the last four games he
still tries to fit it into that tight
window at times which led to trouble
last year at this point this year it
hasn't led to that kind of trouble
talking to Mike gock co-host of Gojo and
gock on DraftKings Network he was on the
Westwood One call last night the Eagles
and the Cowboys what do you make of the
AFC North H well uh Baltimore I think in
in what we thought was the deepest
conference led by Kansas City is now a
conference where you'd have to say
Baltimore is the most balanced team on
both sides of the ball right they have
the same amount of losses as Miami as
Miami gets ready to play tonight and
they play uh in a few weeks so that
could be for the number one seed
depending on if they keep winning or not
but I mean Pittsburgh listen I don't
think anybody fears Pittsburgh it's just
the fact that's Mike Tomlin and he
always has a winning record and if this
team got into the playoffs you would be
like man I I if I'm a team playing him
in the playoffs I'm not fearing them too
much I'm worried more in the AFC quite
honestly Dan if Denver gets into the
playoffs I'm calling the Denver Detroit
game on Saturday Denver is on fire right
now that's a team in the AFC I other
teams should worry about if they get to
the playoffs because it is all about how
you are playing attrition are you
getting healthy by the end of the season
how you playing by the end of the season
Russell Wilson looks so much better
Shawn pton what he's doing he's living
up to what he said he'd do but to me
it's that defense they are playing some
ball right now so the the North
Cleveland I mean Joe Flack
I mean who knew they're four starting
quarterback but they have a great
defense so they're going to be in every
single game good running attack and joku
is starting to break out a little bit um
so I I I have Baltimore as the top most
balanced team in that Division I I have
a hard time believing Pittsburgh's gonna
hang on to that right now they're in the
six slot uh of the of the wild card I
have a hard time believing they're gonna
hang on to that did you play against Joe
flanco yeah I remember I remember you
know Deacon Jones you know trying to
sack him back in the day but uh wow what
what what a rebirth been pretty
incredible you don't might be in a
playoff game Mike yeah yeah and you
don't see many that stationary
quarterbacks anymore in the NFL so that
is and and quite honestly the offensive
line likes that because they love just
cup protecting knowing exactly where
your quarterback is going to be and we
know exactly where he's going to be the
uh 49ers and the
Cowboys I know they've already played
yeah but you know are we looking at a
are they different teams now if if who
would you take if those two faced each
other man I I would I would still take
San Francisco I think they I think they
have more weapons on offense uh for sure
the defensive line has a lot of depth to
it you know we've been talking about
who's at the top of the NFC San
Francisco Dallas and Philadelphia you
know uh but now it's to the point and
they all have the three losses but s
Fran has the the tiebreaker on both for
the number one seed but right now it's
Arrow up Cowboys Arrow up San Francisco
arrow down Philadelphia the way they're
playing right now they're going to get
into the playoffs but I mean we know
that's not enough for Philadelphia it's
you lost in the Super Bowl you got to
get back there that's that's the next
step Dallas is the team that was a game
for them last night Dan that they needed
for all the hype and talk about can they
be back can they get back to the Super
Bowl they needed a win like that after
losing to this team a few weeks ago they
needed this win Plus
they are playing so well right now both
offensively and defensively and again
while Dak is going to get a lot of the
pressing he deserves it I give a lot of
credit to that old line yeah but you
know what and it's not fair to Dallas
not fair to Dak but I want to see what
they do on the road in Buffalo and what
they do in Miami I know they got Detroit
after that but it and then it's going to
be what about the
playoffs of all all the teams it's
Dallas where you go yeah but let's wait
till January so Philly had their
Gauntlet run right uh where they beat
some good teams and lost to some good
teams now it's Dallas's turn so they
they played the co they played the
Eagles as you said now the bills then
the Dolphins then the then the uh uh
lions and we'll see what they're doing
but yeah this is this is kind of their
Gauntlet and it's always going to be
what have you done for me lately for the
Cowboys because everybody's waiting for
them to slip up against a good team and
said there they are same Cowboys can't
get over the hump but you know they
checked that box at at least for the
time being but the next two games are on
the road so like you said they've been
money at home uh can they be money on
the road and then but they're playing so
well at home if somehow they could get
that number one seed and have everything
run through Dallas that would be pretty
impressive but right now that that's
favoring San Francisco safe travels home
thank you for taking time to join us
Mike you got it Dan thanks That's Mike
gooling co-host of Gojo and gock on
DraftKings Network and he was on the
call last night with the Eagles and the
Cowboys